une robe fleurie pour un instant
solennel flora fait partie des modèles
proposés par laurence mercier cette
créatrice installée à chevreuse créé
depuis un an et demi pour les futurs
mariés c'est beau à regarder ça fait
rêver c'est la robe d'un jour c'est
et puis sa réflexion la personnalité de
la mariée quoi donc
c'est aussi ça qui me plaît c'est une
demande unique et c'est une robe unique
d'un jour si laurence mercier n'a pas
été touché par la crise pour maternité
elles placent beaucoup d'espoir dans la
saison 2022 en 2020 seulement 155 mille
mariages ont été célébrés ses 34 % de
moins qu'en 2019 j'ai été obligé de
fermer à cause des confinement est en
fait à partir de demi
mimi mais je crois qu'on a pu réouvrir
alors là je suis passé de zéro à
surcharger il ya une grosse demande en
très peu de temps parce que du coup les
gens ont fini par savoir que leur
mariage était maintenu et on a aussi
senti que même les invités pas forcément
les mariés et le l'entourage proche il
avait vraiment envie de se faire plaisir
création sur base de modèles réalisation
sur mesures comptez entre 1000 et 2500
euros la robe laurence sera présente au
salon du mariage et de la réception de
massy en essonne